cómo
[Música]
hola y bienvenido sea europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy esther herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy hablamos de un tema que lleva
semanas en medio del debate en bruselas
hay que confiscar los bienes de los
oligarcas rusos y las reservas del banco
central de rusia
ahora mismo congeladas por el momento
más de 1000 individuos han sido
sancionados por la unión europea la
comisión europea quiere confiscar los
bienes de aquellos que intenten eludir
las sanciones pero ahora hay que ir más
allá lo hablamos con nuestros invitados
los eurodiputados sumen a cruyff del
grupo socialdemócrata bienvenido mena
bien ayudado muchas gracias y también
con el eurodiputado miguel urbán del
grupo de la izquierda europea bienvenido
miguel muchas gracias muchas gracias a
los dos para poder hablar de este tema
tan interesante la comisión europea ha
propuesto que los oligarcas rusos que
intenten eludir las sanciones aplicadas
por la unión europea tras la invasión de
ucrania se les confisquen los bienes se
intentan eludir las sanciones y este
dinero pueda acabar en manos de las
víctimas de la guerra en ucrania y
también para la reconstrucción qué
opináis de esta medida domenack pues
creo en primer lugar que es de justicia
casi diría de sentido común que estos
bienes que han sido congelados a
miembros de la oligarquía rusa es decir
a la gente que colabora con el régimen
de putin que se beneficia personalmente
y empresarialmente del régimen de putin
puedan ser utilizados precisamente para
la reconstrucción de ucrania hablamos de
30 mil millones de euros es mucho dinero
pero también como decías al principio no
debemos olvidar que el banco central de
rusia dispone de activos en el exterior
congelados por valor de 300 mil millones
de euros por tanto tenemos que trabajar
en diría en los dos carriles justamente
vamos a ver esto en concreto miguel qué
opinas de esta medida de la comisión
europea yo lo resumiría en que
bienvenidos a lo que llevamos diciendo
desde la izquierda ya mucho tiempo las
sanciones tienen que ir dirigidas
la oligarquía que sostiene a putin y no
contra el pueblo ruso porque el problema
es que muchas de las sanciones aprobadas
aquí han ido contra el pueblo ruso y eso
puede llevar incluso problemas de ayuda
humanitaria aparejados a este tipo de
sanciones indiscriminadas contra los que
nada tienen que ver de una ocupación
ilegal como la que estamos viendo en
ucrania eso en primer lugar segundo el
problema es que me parece un maquillaje
un nuevo maquillaje de la comisión
europea porque porque como nosotros
hemos dicho y hemos hecho votar aquí en
diferentes enmiendas cuando se habla de
sanciones y el parlamento europeo ha
votado en contra no se puede sancionar
realmente a la oligarquía rusa sin poder
hacer lo que sería un registro de
propietarios reales vamos a abordar esto
este punto tan interesante en mi guel
pero me gustaría volver un momento a una
de las aportaciones que has hecho
domenech justamente sobre estos 300.000
millones de euros congelados que ahora
mismo que pertenecen al banco central de
rusia recientemente enviaste una carta a
la comisión europea en que pedías que
estos 300 mil millones se confisquen
a las víctimas de la guerra ucrania y
también para la reconstrucción porque
crees que una medida parecida es idónea
bien vivimos a lo mejor en una
pequeña no sé si llamarla pequeña o
grande contradicción tenemos más
seguramente incluso 350 mil millones de
dólares congelados eso quiere decir de
activos del banco central de rusia que
no los pueden utilizar los rusos no
utilizar putin pero tampoco los estamos
utilizando en occidente y al mismo
tiempo sabemos que la reconstrucción de
ucrania va a costar algo así como entre
500 mil millones de euros y 2 billones
de euros esto puede ir además creciendo
si la guerra sigue alargándose por tanto
me parece evidente además de que es una
necesidad es de justicia que utilicemos
esos activos del agresor para la
reconstrucción de ucrania y yo celebro
que esta iniciativa que lanzamos en el
parlamento europeo haya sido ya apoyada
por el alto representante josep borrell
por seas michelle el presidente del
consejo euro e incluso lo hemos visto
reflejado también en las conclusiones
del consejo europeo del 31 de mayo ahora
lo que necesitamos es una propuesta
legislativa de la comisión porque es
verdad que carecemos ahora mismo de una
base legal para poder utilizar esos casi
350.000 millones de dólares de activos
del banco central de rusia miral
estarías de acuerdo yo creo que hay que
poner ciertas dudas a esa propuesta yo
creo que si lo escuchamos así quién va a
estar en contra de ayudar a la
reconstrucción de ucrania de un país
agresor el problema es que yo creo que
hay que hablar de un régimen
agresor el problema es que ahí
estaríamos condenando al conjunto del
pueblo ruso hay una parte muy importante
que se está revelando contra esta
invasión creo que ayudaría más a cerrar
filas con putin y no a debilitar al
gobierno de putin y yo creo que esto es
muy importante las compensaciones de
guerra si vemos incluso la historia
europea nunca han salido bien
normalmente han favorecido conflictos
posteriores y yo creo que lo que hay que
intentar es evitar ese tipo de
conflictos posteriores hay medidas que
pueden ayudar a la
de ucrania y que están en nuestra en
nuestra mano sin cambiar la legislación
como proponía a domenech que se podrían
hacer ya que nosotros hemos propuesto
que se hicieran que es por ejemplo la
condonación de la deuda ucraniana la
condonación de la deuda historia era
ucraniana la condonación de la deuda
exterior cutánea está en manos de los 27
países miembros de la unión europea del
fbi de eeuu y la rusia y se podría
cancelar el 30 por cierto por ejemplo es
de deuda rusa eso supondría un ingreso
inmediato para las arcas ucranianas que
ahora mismo están asfixiadas por el pago
de los intereses de esa misma deuda que
pasa que cuando tocamos también los
bolsillos de los intereses europeos pues
hay menos solidaridad y yo creo que esto
sería una medida efectiva que se podría
hacer mañana sin cambiar la legislación
y que se ha hecho en casos anteriores la
condonación de la deuda alemana por
ejemplo
ha hablado un poco de la cuestión de que
estos trescientos mil millones de euros
hay dudas legales porque no es dinero de
los oligarcas es dinero también público
dinero de los impuestos de rusia podría
ser una medida incluso impopular dentro
de la población rusa bueno es un poco el
argumento que ha hecho miguel yo diría
de entrada que lo que él propone de la
condonación de la una parte o de una
gran parte de la deuda pública ucraniana
es una medida que me parece interesante
y no es incompatible por otro lado con
lo que estamos proponiendo
puede ser que cause algún grado de
impopularidad en rusia que nos hagamos
con el control efectivo de esos activos
pero en cualquier caso tendremos que
pensar en otras medidas a futuro cuando
acabe la guerra para ayudar directamente
al pueblo ruso
sin reforzar el régimen de putin pero me
parece insostenible en la situación
actual renunciar a la utilización en
favor del pueblo ucraniano
más de 300 mil millones de dólares que
no pueden quedarse
yo creo permanentemente en el limbo
recordemos que ahora mismo tampoco los
puede utilizar y es correcto que así sea
el régimen de putin pero yo creo que hay
otras fórmulas y eso es lo que nosotros
estamos defendiendo pero no nosotros a
la izquierda en abstracto vuelva a
repetir economistas como piketty y otros
lo han puesto por escrito si se sabe
quién es la oligarquía rusa es muy
sencillo el propio piquet y lo ha
expuesto de una forma clara es todo el
mundo en rusia que tengan más de 10
millones de euros en activos o en
pasivos es oligarquía rusa que se ha
beneficiado el régimen de putin con lo
cual está señalando a quien puedes
justamente golpear para debilitar a
putin para acabar cuanto antes con la
guerra y sobre todo para atacar a los
verdaderos culpables de esta invasión el
problema es que una medida
indiscriminada como el tema no de la
congelación sino de la incautación de
los fondos del dinero público porque hay
que decir que es del dinero público
lo que estaría haciendo a día de hoy
sería reforzar la lógica de la guerra de
putin reforzar al régimen de putin y
condenar al conjunto del pueblo ruso a
una carestía que yo creo que no se
merece en estos momentos y que además
táctica y estratégicamente para el
objetivo de buscar la paz yo creo que
sería contraproducente por eso no estoy
contra poniendo una medida con la otra
yo lo que estoy diciendo es que tenemos
medidas que pueden paliar
inmediatamente sin cambiar la
legislación y sin reforzar al régimen de
putin para el pueblo ucraniano que es
atacar a su oligarquía atacamos la base
del régimen de putin y evidentemente
acabar con las deudas que ahora mismo
tienen pues apretado la economía de
ucrania y del pueblo ucraniano eso se
puede hacer mañana mismo sin cambiar la
legislación la única diferencia es que
eso también supone un esfuerzo por parte
de las instituciones europeas y de las
oligarquías europeas el único cambio que
necesitaríamos hacer sería el construir
un registro
propietarios reales de los paraísos
fiscales que existen en europa y eso
sería acabar con los paraísos fiscales
por cierto sería un gran beneficio para
la mayoría de la población europea según
la comisión europea
estos mismos evasores europeos se llevan
un billón de euros de nuestros impuestos
cada año según la comisión europea sí
pero si me permites vamos a ver vayamos
por partes el tema de la oligarquía ya
lo estamos haciendo se podrá hacer mejor
nos irá haciendo bueno no son mil el
problema es que son según piquet y son
exime a mil personas si se podrá ir a
más pero tenemos ya confiscado bienes de
la oligarquía rusa por valor de 30 mil
millones de euros o sea que no se puede
decir que ahí no se está haciendo nada
pero una cosa si me permites que te
pregunte pero entonces tú estás con esa
idea tuya de que sólo podemos ir contra
la oligarquía estás entonces en contra
de que dejemos de comprar gas y petróleo
a rusia porque eso claramente afecta al
conjunto del país no sólo en la garcía
primero no es una idea mía vuelvo a
repetir en más de 150 economías europeos
por parte de economistas
socialdemócratas han planteado
justamente cómo se deben de orientar el
tema de las
en este caso ataques oligarquías de
sanciones y demás y hay que decir una
cosa muy importante también
este tipo de sanciones se suelen volver
como un boomerang contra nosotros y el
problema es que la unión europea está
utilizando la guerra como una coartada
para hacer muchos cambios estratégicos
un cambio muy importante es que de
repente la energía nuclear es verde
tiene mucho que ver con el petróleo el
gas tiene mucho que ver justamente con
el petróleo el gas estamos defendiendo
que la energía
nuclear es verde porque no podemos
comprar petróleo y gas ruso yo creo que
hay medidas mucho más efectivas y
urgentes que se podrían tomar mañana
mismo y eso no se está haciendo y eso es
porque no se está haciendo un elemento
no me queda claro si estás a favor o en
contra de él porque lo siento nos hemos
quedado sin tiempo realmente movimiento
mucho tener que
ver
si estás a favor o en contra
yo voto a favor en contra de la
abolición de la deuda externa ucraniana
pero
el petróleo
que yo he hecho las propuestas
una segunda parte de él se levante según
sin duda me reservo en vuestro tiempo
para una próxima vez a ustedes gracias
por ver france 24 en español les
esperamos en el próximo programa de
europa hoy
[Música]